All right. Welcome, everybody to another Zoom call number of questions came through. So that's good.
It's the reminder of to check the members only site for announcements.
And another reminder that you could all get out of any of our courses.
So make sure you check as well.
All right. So let's jump into some questions here.
Very small computer screens. I'm going to move this around a little bit.
Which Burberry would you suggest for me to add to my protocol?
A day is the question which Burberry to add to the call and how many a day?
If I can get to it, I'll make a computer screen is so small.
All right. So you guys can see that it's really small but apologize.
The Burberry clear is our private labeled Burberry to designs for health Burberry.
So the reason why I like it is it's got Burberry and ALA.
It makes it so good for cancer patients.
So Burberry clear in at three per day and try to split it up as best you can.
I know some people are like, oh, I'm not very good at split up by supplements.
Well, then take two of the morning or one of the evening. If you can split it up morning lunch time and dinner, that would even be better.
And it was hard for some people to do that. It's hard for me to do that.
Burberry clear is the better Burberry. It's a great Burberry.
How long do you have to wait to take supplements before your blood work or doesn't not matter?
It doesn't really matter at all. So your supplements shouldn't affect your blood work really at all.
So when you're getting just a CBC or a complete metabolic panel or you're getting full testing for food sensitivities or anything your supplements taking your supplements right before you do your blood work.
It literally has no effect on your blood work. I'm not seeing anything about supplements and affect on your blood work.
So you don't have to worry about that.
The only thing I will say about blood work is that it's always best to do it 12 hour fast.
So I know sometimes that's just not convenient. You're going in to get a blood test at four o'clock in the afternoon. You wouldn't fast it all day.
A lot of the blood markers a fast really makes no difference. It does make a difference on your glucose levels and some other factors, some other markers as well.
Definitely your glucose levels. Now with the advent of homeowners and people that have a whole glucometer, you know, your glucose level on your blood test on a CBC makes little.
You know, you're not really looking at that. Then if you're able to measure your own glucose levels throughout the day and post, you know, eating something so it's not as make a deal but typically it's always better to do a 12 hour fast before you're doing any blood work.
You'd want a schedule in a perfect case scenario schedule your blood work to go in at nine o'clock or eight o'clock in the morning to get your blood work and you haven't eaten since eight o'clock at night before.
That's going to be your best thing. That's going to be your best picture to get your blood work.
The other good thing to look at when you get blood work done.
Is that you do it at the same time each time you do it. So if you let's say you're getting blood work every month or every three months or every six months, you try to schedule it at nine o'clock in the morning every time you go to get your blood work done.
And you do a 12 hour fast on each one. You're going to get just more accurate comparisons.
The objections or comments on the treatments proposed for me at the immunotherapy institute in T1. So this person sent me a proposal from this Mexico cancer clinic in Tijuana, what they want to do for her.
No, I think it looks great. And if you feel led to go down there and do that, there's there's a lot of different, you know, semi invasive therapies that would could be really great. So I looked over it early this morning. And I thought it was a great bit. So do I think for you specifically, is it necessary where you're at right now.
No, but I mean, again, if you feel led to do that, then by all means to do that, I don't know if you made the step to talk to the surgeon yet, if you had that appointment, whether that how that went, whether they're going to do a lump back to me, or they're still pushing you for a mastectomy.
I don't know. So if they're if you're good planning on doing the Tijuana visit prior to that, or you're going to go do the surgery, do the lump back to me, or they're pushing you for a mastectomy.
I don't know.
So, but I did like their proposal and looked great. Do I think you particular I need to do that. No, but if you get a few lead to that, I don't see anything any problem with that whatsoever.
I have not received any information on my genetic review as of yet. So this person who sent this is not on the call right now doesn't look like.
And please check your email because I sent out your genetic information I looked two days after Christmas on the 27th. So please check your email. I sent you out all three reports in two separate emails.
So you should have that by now. So, you know, I have to make sure the email went through the email did go through. It might be in your spam folder, maybe.
But look at that. I make sure you got that. Your recommendation for your growth was minimum of 15 capitals capsules of digestimes plus in the morning and the same in the evening 30 minutes away from food. So understand that protocol that is Dr William Kelly's
protocol for enzymes therapy. So enzyme therapy for cancer is to be taking high dose of pancreatic enzymes that you would take on an empty stomach.
So high doses of pancreatic enzymes on an empty stomach so that you absorb them and the idea is that the enzymes can help break down the cancer and the slime layer around the cancer so that your immune system could better get at it and attack it.
Now, Dr Kelly's protocol is really best for cancers of the intestinal tract, cancers of the pancreas, cancers of the liver, and maybe bile duct cancer.
That's where really shines is those types of cancers.
Certainly, it's a therapy that should be attempted by anybody if the other therapies are not working. The reason why I say, well, why don't you just jump into that right away.
The negative of it is that you're taking so darn many pills. We're using 15 to 30 digestimes in the morning and in the evening and you have to take it about 30 minutes away from food and you can see in this person's questions.
I did not get up to about 2 p.m. going to bed at 9.30. I have a smoothie or 10 a.m. in bed. I took 15 enzymes around 9 a.m. and threw up a half hour later. That's not uncommon. That's a problem.
So, stomach was queasy for five to six hours and it up stayed in bed even longer. The next time I took four of them, about 7 p.m. by stomach hurt for four hours. The next time I tried to take two, and I could still feel it in my stomach, but it was tolerable help.
You have to work up on it. This is an issue. So, Dr Nicholas Gonzalez was one of who was one of my teachers.
He taught me about Dr Kelly's protocols. He was very big into Dr Kelly's protocols, and he actually wrote several books on Dr William Kelly.
I had long discussions with him about Dr William Kelly. I highly admire him, but a lot of people can't do it.
You realize that the pills, the pancreatic enzymes that they had at the time, and that Dr Gonzalez was using 15 years ago, were at a dosage that he had to have people take 75 pills in the morning and 75 pills at night before they went to bed.
I don't know how anybody could swallow 150 of the pills a day, plus they were taking other supplements. I just don't know how people could do it. Well, the truth was, a lot of people, there's just a way they could do it. It was pretty minimal amount of people that they could do that.
Now, with the advent of the fermented digestimes, plus, which is so much higher dose per capsule, we could get by with taking a lot less of them.
The problem still exists as in this person's questions, an example of this person's questions. One thing that you could do is you could open them up and put them in the smoothie.
It could be actually the capsule itself that is causing stomach upset. That's very possible that it's the capsule itself. So I would try two things.
If you're like, there's no way I can open up these capsules, then I would start really small and start with two in the morning, two at night.
If you can open up the capsules, I would start opening up and maybe start with maybe three or four in your smoothie in the morning and three or four in some type of smoothie drink in the evening.
Well, you're supposed to take them away from food. Can I take them with my smoothie? Yes, take them with your smoothie. You'll get some of some of the enzymes wasted digesting the smoothie, but you're not getting you're not eating a whole meal and having them wasted that way. That's the way I would do it if I were you.
I want to address this question that came in here curious why you think the MX clinic is unnecessary is a lump back to me easier, cheaper, better.
PS the surgeon hasn't called me. Yes, I don't I don't think that going to the Mexico clinic is going to be a replacement for the lump back to me or the mass neck to me. I just don't think that that's going to happen.
Going to the Mexico clinic is going to make this shrink and disappear down to zero.
Anything's possible. God can do anything, but I don't think that a will and I know you're interested in trying to save your notes.
It's if if you have the ability to go down there and do it and your surgeon still hasn't even called you yet.
And you can get out there and do this and try this and see if you could get even more shrinkage by all means go for it. I'm all for a hundred percent.
Alright, this question I'm interested in running a short right program prior to my nightly cancer program.
How do I set up the system before going to bed so that it will run two sessions in sequence without having to wake up to launch the second program.
This is what is called program stacking.
So I have a video on the right section about stacking programs. I'll look and make sure.
But Mike in his true right videos has a video on stacking programs.
I don't do that.
So I can't remember off the top of my head how to do that but it's really a simple function how to pick a program and then you pick another program and you.
There's some things that you do on the right thing on the right program and you stack it and you hit run and it'll play the first program and it'll play the second program and that's it's very simple.
It's about a four minute video on how to stack programs. I'll find it and I'll put it up on the member site.
If it's not there already called stacking programs.
When I do my foot bath, I am getting slight pain in my liver area.
Is it possible that there is still cancer in this area is this good or something to be concerned about.
I don't think that when you do the foot bath, getting paid in your liver area is suggestive that there's still cancer in the area.
I don't think that is a correlative suggestion that you could make any type of stretch or diagnosis with that.
Whenever you have pain doing a foot bath program or a right program, it could be just because the frequencies are affecting that area some way.
This is where I created that video, good pain versus bad pain with cancer.
It's almost always when you are running a right program and you have you feel a little tingle or you feel a little pain anywhere in your body.
Almost 100% of the time it's a good pain. It's a good thing. Those frequencies are affecting that area and that's a good thing.
I do not think it's suggestive that there's cancer there. It could be just your body is just pulling the garbage out of your liver.
It's helping stimulate detoxification pathways.
The only way to know if there's cancer there is to do a scan or some sort of medical procedure to look at that again.
Are you familiar with the emotional code? The emotional code is a book that's out there and they have a website and there's different tapping things that you do with the emotional code.
It's part of E, what was it called emotional freedom technique, EFT.
So emotional code stemmed off of emotional freedom technique.
For people looking for help with emotional healing.
It could be attributed to their cancer. If so, do you think this is in line with Christianity or something outside of the Christian faith?
I don't think it's outside of the Christian faith. I read the emotional code book years ago.
I used to teach some EFT. There's nothing do age about it. There's nothing anti Christian about it whatsoever.
It's literally tapping on different acupuncture points to stimulate different changes in your body and how you're neurologically connected to an emotion because you talk through a blockage in your in your emotions.
Take a step back from a neurological perspective. If I let's say, let's say, okay, let's use this example because everybody's probably experienced this. I remember when I was a kid.
My sister made these homemade ice cream sandwiches. She made this the cookie part and then she got some ice cream and she made these ice cream sandwiches out of these cookies and she froze them.
They were delicious. I had one of them and then I ended up getting the flu. I don't know. I was like 10 years old, eight years old. I ended up getting the flu and I got sick.
And then I got stuck in my mind that I will never eat one of those ice cream sandwiches again because it was right after I ate those ice cream sandwiches and I picked it up this bug and I got sick.
It was there anything physiological about that ice cream sandwich that made me feel nausea thinking about eating ice cream sandwiches or anything that second me with because of that ice cream sandwich that caused my sickness.
No, so it was all an emotional high. And from a neurological perspective, your prefrontal cortex makes emotional makes neurological connections with a deeper part of the brain called the amygdala.
So that just stimulated this amygdala connection. So every time I saw an ice cream sandwich my brothers and sisters were eating one of those ice cream sandwiches a week later. Oh my gosh, I just felt sick. I had to go the other home. I couldn't even see them anymore.
Now, again, nothing physiological about the chemistry of that ice cream sandwiches. It was physiological in my brain on the neurological connection of my prefrontal cortex vision viewing the ice cream sandwich and firing back to the my amygdala this emotional deep seated emotional pain that I had because of being, you know, violently ill with the flu.
So it is with so many things of our life we end up having these prefrontal cortex that's the frontal part of your brain that is your coordinator of your brain. It's the executive of the brain.
You view something that you decide what that thing means to you based upon past experiences that if you had a deep seated emotional experience with that thing.
That is rooted in that deep part of the brain called the amygdala. You could have a violent reaction when you view that thing.
Same thing if you were in a bad car accident. Same thing if you, you know, you could there's a zillion examples of this and you probably have thought of someone telling you my example.
Well, using techniques like emotional freedom technique and the emotional code it's simply stimulating different points on your body while you're thinking of that thing to help break that neurological connection in your brain and it really does work.
I remember a gal who was a patient of mine. This is probably 20 years ago and she was in her late 50s at the time and she came to one of my nice to have these weekly seminars and I was teaching on emotional freedom technique.
And she said, I have to go to the dentist tomorrow and I have to get I have to get knocked out every time I go to the dentist because I have this fear.
This deep deep seated fear of dental work.
And we literally did emotional freedom technique. So she kind of volunteered to be the example of this and she came back the next week said, I went to dentist. I did not have to get knocked out.
I was able to get convocated. I did the whole dental procedure and it was just amazing. And this is this is since I was just a little kid because she had this horrible experience with the dentist, which was like seven years old.
So this stuff really does work things that you know, how are neurological connections in the brain fire back to deep seated emotional experiences are real.
I can't belittle those things.
Now the psychiatric profession just meditates people to numbness so that they don't feel those things. Well, I guess that can't work too, but how bad is that for you using things like the emotional code and emotional freedom technique can be very, very beneficial.
I don't think, you know, I said, I studied a lot of this stuff. There is nothing anti spiritual about them. So the people, maybe there are people that teach this stuff now that are way out of the new age spectrum. Don't, don't just call that but in general, the procedure is just straight physiology.
It's nothing wrong with it whatsoever.
This person asked this question because I keep forgetting to talk about it. So there seems to be a lot of concern about the recent purchase of true right. So true right was purchased by a doctor out of Texas.
The, another guy for his own Texas.
Now, I didn't know about this. Tell about six weeks ago. The purchase actually went through about three months ago and Mike who owned to rife and started to rife is still with the company that he'll be with the company for another three months or so.
He'll always be available to communicate with so the company has issues. If the company has any issues.
Well, I had called Mike to ask him a question about something about six weeks ago. And he said, oh, here, I want you to talk to a doctor. I'm sorry, I don't remember his name. You can look up true rights. They just put up a brand new website that's much nicer than their old website.
The doctor who owns it is not a little biography on the website so you can look at it. I can't remember his name off the top of my head. So I was able to chat with that doctor for about half hour, 45 minutes and to chat with his partner, who is going to be mainly the managing director there doing what Mike did there.
I had to handle it all the everything that is going on. Understand, they're retaining all their other employees. Nobody's getting let go or replaced. So I was shocked at the beginning with Mike didn't even tell me that he was selling the company, but it came out of the blue for him too.
So later he talked to me about it that he was thinking of selling it. He's in his, you know, mid seventies and he's like, I got to move on, you know, in my life, and I'm just ready to retire.
And this guy came out of the blue and offered to buy the company. So after talking to the doctor, who's buying the company for about 45 minutes, I was very, very pleased. I think the company's going to go even a better direction.
So, you know, if if any of you have talked to Mike at true life over the last couple of years, he's the nicest guy on the planet, right, he's a nice guy, but he gets really crappy too. So, especially if it's been a long day, and he's been dealing with a lot of people that are crabbing at him, he gets very short fused.
And we've not complaints from our patients members about how they were treated by Mike at times and we got great compliments how people love Mike.
So it really depended on how you caught him. Well, he's been super happy for the last three months because, you know, he's going to be moving on in life.
So, I think they're making really good positive changes. The owner of the company, his wife is a triathlete.
They are very, he's a medical doctor, but he's a very functional medicine doctor from, from Texas.
They want to move the company in a direction where it's going to, where they're going to make it their true life more available to athletes and people that just want to stay healthy, which is exciting.
Now, I do know the price of all their stuff is going up just because the price of their prop their components are going up. So that isn't an issue.
I think the company's going to go in a very good direction. So I'm not a part of any of the, the right Facebook groups or discord groups.
So I don't know what people are saying about it.
I got nothing, but positive. I think it's going to be really good. I do know their prices are going to go up five to seven percent. I think starting January 15th, we're not changing any of our costs or our prices.
It is, it, you know, price of everything's going up. I mean, yeah, it just is what it is.
But no, I'm very positive about it. I was like blown away when I first heard about it. I thought, oh, great.
But no, I'm very positive. I think it's going to go in a better direction.
Mike was very inventive and do we do things? I think this company is even going to go this older is going to even go farther. I think I'm really actually excited about everything in what's going on.
Okay, back to your questions here.
Are infrared sauna okay? If my kidneys feel like they are struggling a bit.
Yes, I think far infrared sauna is very okay. Make sure you're drinking lots of water. That's my only thing you don't want to be hydrated dehydration on your kidneys is the hardest thing on your kidneys.
So make sure you're drinking a lot of water.
I did OT for two consecutive days and sweat a lot. Third day, felt like my kidneys were struggling a bit. I've been drinking lots of lemon water and added some trace minerals and electrolytes.
Also, can trace minerals and electrolytes cause kidney issues. So I don't know which trace minerals you're talking about. If you're talking about trace minerals that are the liquid trace minerals.
Throw them away. Don't use those. Use the all beyond trace minerals like our brand, the clear multimin plus are my favorite ones or are clear multimin use those trace minerals, not a liquid trace minerals.
They can liquid trace minerals are are elemental minerals, meaning like right out of the ground and you're they don't do well. You don't absorb them well and they're hard on your kidneys. So don't be taking those.
I spoke about the right form of minerals a while back and you want to be making sure you're taking minerals in the form that they were created to be consumed did which would be plant based minerals that has a double bond amino acid the only ones that you can get that way are they'll say I'll be on or tracks on the back of the bottle.
They're not a liquid product. They are a powder product could be an issue with too much oxalate in my system.
Yeah, but the if you're drinking lots of water and you're flushing out your kidneys the soda is really, really good for you.
It doesn't matter if I use medium roast or light roast for my animals.
No, they don't work exactly the same so the light roast of the golden rose that we have that we sell in our store is specifically for animals you wouldn't drink that it's it's not roasted very much at all.
Because the lighter the roast of more caffeine in it the more it's going to stimulate the the the parasympathetics now.
Again, if you're doing my easy peasy animal prescription that's on the membership site, you're just you just roasting any coffee you know it's just hey that's better than doing nothing.
So don't get too hung up on that don't beat yourself. Oh, I got to get this.
This is going to be the magic secret is going to get this light roast. No, so you're just doing the coffee animals.
I don't care if you're using Starbucks.
Okay, so don't don't use Starbucks, but use an organic plant would be best.
I had to get off my vegan diet a month ago because I was losing too much weight got down to 94 pounds. That's not good.
I'm five foot one and a half inches.
I'm having a problem eating food as I am scared to eat anything don't be scared to eat anything.
I was eating peanut butter and banana sandwiches all day as it's called my stomach.
How do I change my mindset it's mostly psychological I'm sure yes, I would say so you got to chill out about your diet.
Remember we say in your binder your diet is just your diet. It's a guideline. It's not a religion. Okay, so it's not going to be a maker break thing.
So eat you got to eat some food you got to get your your your weight back up start enjoying it. God gave you this this food to eat doesn't mean you go and eat a McDonald's hamburger, but
just eat some food and enjoy food. It's some read the book on Galatians and don't beat yourself up over your diet. Okay, you're not a Pharisee don't act like one.
I sent you several questions from the website form a two 30 central standard time.
I put them here right now, sorry if they're too long for the chat or maybe you want to look at them.
Did you I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I missed your question that got my two workers run again, but had to go with lab core November 10th and quest December 29th.
Okay, so let me just chat on that really quick. You can get different readings from different labs.
So that's just, you know, they have different instrumentation.
You could even get different readings from the exact same lab if you were in the hospital, if you got a lab done and you got a lab done with the get of the hospital five minutes later, you can get a different reading because they're counting white blood cells.
And such that it just is a different lab technician and it can be off. So certainly with different labs, you can get different readings.
Right, not sure how to interpret these results compared.
Been doing a color's clinic program for ER plus breast cancer since October 16th. My results, the CEA November, in November 1.8 in December 1.3.
So this is the CEA 19.9 is basically a mute point for you.
CEA is within normal range for you.
The CEA 125, this one, it seems I got closer to the upper range 32 and 37. Again, even if this is the same lab, a change a difference from 32 to 37. That's still within the margin of error there.
So I would even be concerned about that CEA 153 29.8 to 22. Well, that you're starting to go a little bit beyond the margin of error in the good direction. So that's good.
See the difference in what different lab calls normal 0 to 25 was lab core and quest is then less than 32, just a little bit different range difference.
There's nothing set and stone with ranges.
How do I read the sense one went up and the other went down, but they're all still with the normal range.
You're still doing your I'd say you're doing great. You you still want them to spike. So what you're looking for, let's say, see, let's look at the CA 2729 as an example, this is really the only one that.
So this one of the CA 153 that you can really use markers because they're the only ones that are close to being outside of normal.
And you see even the 29.8 would have ended within normal range on the quest lab.
Because these these normal ranges are not set in stone. They're just something that, you know, lab that that that the medical impression has picked over a period of time that this is within normal range.
And it's just like when I graduated back in the 1980s, normal cholesterol was, you know, if you were abnormal, if you were over 250, then they dropped it down to to 20, then 200 and now it's 180, why?
Because they can sell more drugs to lipitor to people if they dropped the normal doubt. Yeah, I'm sorry, it's cynical, but it's true.
How do I read these? I'd say you're looking for changes how you read your labs, you're looking for changes and you're looking for fairly, fairly dramatic changes.
So a change from 32 to 37, all that went up. Yeah, well, it's still kind of within the within range of what you think would is not really a jump.
You're looking at if you had a jump from 32 to 58, you know, okay, that's a jump. That's what you're looking for, gross changes like that.
So another word on tour markers, it's like, okay, you have a tour marker of, you know, let's look at your ca 99 of less than two, right?
That means it's normal in people with even no cancer to have a ca 99.
If you had a, if yours was 25, you know, zero to 35 is normal. So this isn't specifically telling a person that they have cancer.
You can have this enzyme marker, even if you don't have cancer.
So that's why they're just markers. They're not definitive diagnostic tests. They're just markers. They give us clues.
So when you look at these, you run them first to get kind of a baseline.
And now you're looking for, you know, major changes. So what you'd be concerned with is if your ca 15 three was 29 eight back in November.
And now it's 74 in December. That would be a red flight concern. Okay. Is there anything else I could do to be more aggressive.
You know, there's positives and negatives to be super aggressive too. So no, I think you're going in the right direction. Keep going in the right direction.
And to answer your question, I know you and some other people have concern about why I can't do.
Can't do cheek swabs anymore. How am I going to know I'm going to go to the right direction. I'm trying to work on a workaround with that.
I'm out of the office this week. Next week when I get back to the office, I know a number of you said did possible days of doing a protocol zoom.
And I work, try to work on a workaround to keep us legal and doing looking at protocols over a zoom in an educational format that we can stay completely legal. So.
Hi, Dr. Cutters. I emailed a copy of my labs to the clinic.
My alkaline phosphatase is trending up, but it's still within range. But now be a good time to reassess my protocol.
Yeah, let me look at that. I didn't see those labs hold on while we're talking here to let me see.
Can you do what you will you email that to.
Can you email that again? I don't see it in the emails at all. So can you email that again to info, I end F all at Cutters clinic and.
And then I'll look at that again.
If you're still within normal range.
Well, let me look at it again and let you know.
All right, I guess my question didn't go through my Dutch results showed low methylation.
You said it's not a problem.
You said it's not a problem of less homocysteen is high.
I just did that test and it came back at 21.3. Yes, that's high. We need to add some methyl groups.
So it's, I mean, nothing is ever simple, but honestly, it's a fairly simple fix.
Do the question and do you have the methylated B vitamins at home?
So let's go to the slide here.
So methylated B vitamins would be five.
Methyl tetra hydrolate, or it would be, and or I should say, methyl cobalamine.
If you have those products at home, so five methyl tetra hydrolate is your methylated folate.
And methyl cobalamine is your methylated B12.
We just want to start taking some of that and you should start at make sure you're taking.
I would say less than one gram of this.
For a day, oops.
So if it's 500 milligrams or 1000 milligrams, don't take any more than that.
There are some supplements on the market that are like five grams of methyl tetra hydrolate.
Do not start with something like that.
Taking too much methyl tetra hydrolate will push a different pathway called the biopterate pathway.
Really, really hard.
And if you have any defects in the biopterate pathway, you're going to you're going to have some emotional issues.
Because you can you can create way too much serotonin.
That's the most common thing.
And then you get some rage issues.
And we don't want you beating anybody up or hurting your spouse.
So methyl cobalamine, there's really no upper limit on this within reason.
So any of the supplements that are out there with the methyl cobalamine, just take follow what's on the bottle for that.
But make sure you don't take it anymore than one gram of a methyl tetra hydrolate.
What is the new true rife website?
It's the same.
It's true rife.com.
So they just they were the website was down.
Last week because they were rebuilding it.
They just it just looks much nicer.
So they had the website completely just redone, which needed to be refreshed.
So it looks really nice.
I just went to it just to have an hour.
So it is working.
This one is for Tony again, did send the form.
Sorry.
I don't I didn't see it.
For the squamous cell cancer on this time until what is the best scan to follow up with to gauge progress.
You really want to do scans on base upon what was done before.
So you want to compare apples to apples.
So that's how you did an MRI before.
And you want to see progress do another MRI.
And that's what they showed the size of the size that I set you do another CT.
But the question really is why?
You know, it less you're going to.
Do a medical procedure that, you know, they're going to recommend you know what I'm not saying you shouldn't.
But if, if you're considering doing radiation or chemotherapy then by all means, you know, best to compare apples to apples, best to compare.
the study that showed the size and diagnosed the size and measurement of it before,
to see if you're only doing this for curiosity sake, you have to ask yourself the question,
why? Because there is in race and this to an MRI, there's certainly more of base of this to a CT scan
with the radiation, but there's still a base of this within MRI. So
I would, if you swallow it better, what you're saying, then I would say continue your role that you're
going right now, unless you're considering doing some sort of other standards of care.
Sure, if the cancer is spreading, I know only a biopsy could be 100% diagnosed,
want to poke more holes into it, yeah, totally agree. Is there a time to consider the
conventional treatments? Yes, I do. I think there's always a time to consider. I think you should
consider it all the time. But again, that's where you're praying about your decision and asking God to,
hey, do I need to do something else? And again, maybe God's going to lead you to do something else.
I've said this 100 times before, God wanted me to do chemo for the sole reason to witness to some
chemo nurse, I would have done it. But you know, in my prayer time and prayer life, praying about what I
should do, I just felt like that he was not leading me down that pathway. So and you don't want to be,
I've said this 1000 times before, you don't want to be dogmatically positioned like, I would never
do chemo ever, ever, ever. I just don't think that's wise. I mean, you got to be open to, you know,
to be wise in your decision. I've seen patients that, you know, did chemo and that's what saved their
life is doing that chemo. Maybe they didn't have to follow through in every six, you know, sessions or
12 sessions, but doing a little bit help knock it down. And I've also seen people that got
frightened into doing something like that. That was their demise. So don't use that fear. Don't make
any decision based upon fear. Don't make a decision based upon being dogmatically positioned either.
Say, you know, hey, you know, I'm going to do what I need to do. I'm going to use wisdom. But if I
move it in the right directions, then I'm going to keep moving in the right direction. So I got full
blood labs in June and then a December total cholesterol. Good. So it's a little chat on cholesterol
talked about this a lot before, but one of the worst things for cancer patients having low cholesterol.
So cholesterol is your precursor for vitamin D as the sun hits your skin. It changes a chemical in
your skin called seven hydroxy cholesterol, which is derived from circulating cholesterol. So one of
the dangers of people going to lipitor and cholesterol lowering drugs is that they end up with a vitamin D
deficiency because they can't convert the sun. The vitamin D that they normally get from the sun
into vitamin D so they don't get vitamin D for the sun. Besides the fact that lipitor damage is
your liver in so many ways too. HDL is down LDL still about the same glucose. Yeah, you're still
fighting glucose range. A1C, great insulin, fantastic, alkaline, I think that's alkaline, phosphatase,
AstLT. So everything else is looking great. High sensitivity CRP is really a function of inflammation.
C-reactive protein is really the breakdown of inflammatory cytokines in your liver.
Few years ago, they came up with a test called the high sensitivity CRP to try to get more specific
on cytokines that could be affected your vascular system, but it's really not that specific.
Everything else looks good. Yeah, ferritin. I would be concerned about ferritin.
Ferritin is really high. It's actually inflammatory marker. So everything else is great.
T3, if the only thing it was done is your TSH and T3, it's not a complete thyroid panel.
So you'd really want to get a T4 or T3 uptake. Reverse T3, TPO,
antibody test done to really get a good picture of T3. T3 and TSH can change
throughout the day and day by day too. So that's not enough to diagnose thyroid issues.
Regarding the methylation, since you said I'm getting lots of natural methyl groups in my diet,
heavy ingredients, should I be looking for root causes? No, I would not. It really has to do with your
genetics. There's not really any other root causes of a lack of methyl groups, but your
genetics, your MTHFR gene and your MTR and your MTRR genes are really your root causes.
But again, even if a person has those genetic defects, it doesn't mean they're going to have
major issues, but certainly it predisposes to them to that. And if you did not have cancer,
I probably would put you on methyl groups, having those defects. So I think it's time to
just go on there. Can you say the e-mail for labs? Again, info, info at tires, clinics, and
two, I-N-F-O-A-C-O-N-E-R-S, clinic.com. If you said good to CO in an O-R-S, it will not get to me. So
yep, you can still e-mail the labs, and we can talk about, we can make the others
call our labs protocol. And I'm actually coming out in January, I'm going to put out a whole
bunch of videos on the triperty labs for you, which I think will be beneficial. I'm going to go
through the CBC. I'm going to go through a complete metabolic panel and a whole bunch of things
and just break it down into real good usable data. How soon to retest homocysteine,
go three months? So why the rise when my diet is higher in methyl groups? Well,
I don't know, I mean your diet is higher in fiber and other things too, so you might not be
absorbing as many methyl groups as you may have been eating fairly well beforehand, too. Which
measurement is more accurate, MRI or ultrasound. It depends on what your journey to measure. So,
okay, so let's say if you go in, okay, here's a perfect real life example. Somebody told me
the other day that they were having upper right quadrant pain. This was not a cancer patient,
and they suspected of gallstones, that history of gallstone issues, went to the ER and they did
a CT scan. And they said, it's not gallstones, maybe you have an ulcer, that's what they said,
and they sent her home. And this person said, I've had ulcers before. This is a
dead ulcer, it doesn't feel like an ulcer. And they just said, well, we don't know. Okay, CT scan
is not the test that you run for gallstones. Ultrasound is the test for gallstones. Why did they not
do it ultrasound? It's far less expensive. I hate to say, I hate to be so cynical, but her insurance
probably covered a CT scan. And they made a whole bunch more money on a CT scan. Oh boy, it's
this ridiculous. So, to end up what you're looking for. So, an ultrasound is better for certain things,
an MRI is better for other things, more soft tissue things, a CT scan is much better for
bony things, like bony changes. So, if you are suspecting like metastasis cancer to the lumbar spine,
the proper test would be a PET scan, and a CT scan. If you're suspecting metastasis to the liver,
the proper test would be an MRI, or an ultrasound, an MRI would show it better though.
If you're suspecting gallstones, the proper test is an ultrasound. If you want to measure a mass
in your breast, with using the least amount of invasiveness, then you'd pick an ultrasound.
If you want to look for metastasis to have a breast cancer, if you're suspecting bony metastasis,
you know, again, PET scan, and a CT scan. If you're suspecting soft tissue metastasis,
it, or in the lung, a more proper test would be an MRI. There was an X-ray in any of those things,
that's what it would have been, you know, 35 years ago. But since they perfected an MRI and CT scan,
a PET scan, those have shrubs that. Thank you. I will look at that.
Alkaline phosphatase. Hold on. While I have you, hold on.
While I'm not down, hold on. All right.
I already had to unload it really weird with my phone. So, okay. So, yeah, your alkaline phosphatase
is going up a little bit. Hold on. Really quick. Let me look at something else.
So, always with a raise, a rise in alkaline phosphatase, did they say anything about... So, I
ask you in this question about the alkaline phosphatase. Still with the normal limits.
Did they do any other testing to look for the possible metastasis? So, if it was me, if I was your
oncologist, I may walk to just... I would possibly suggest a PET scan. If they did a PET scan recently,
when was your last PET scan, that would be my question. Again, you're still with the normal limits.
Certainly, alkaline phosphatase could rise. So, let's talk about that. What could cause alkaline
phosphatase to rise? Congestion of the liver is the first thing that you think of with elevated alkaline
phosphatase. So, someone who does not have a diagnosis of cancer, you think of a congestion of the
liver. Taking M-sats, so Tylenol, Advil, could cause elevation of alkaline phosphatase. Taking
other medication could cause elevation of alkaline phosphatase because it's irritant to the liver.
So, those are your first things that you look at. With a diagnosis of cancer, the other thing that can
cause elevated alkaline phosphatase is bode metastasis. So, if there's metastasis to any bode,
that's causing lytic metastasis. We'll cause elevation in alkaline phosphatase. So, that's a
differential diagnosis that you want to rule out. What's going on with my liver? Typically, if I have
metastasis to my liver from cancer, that's not necessarily going to cause elevated alkaline phosphatase.
It's congestion of the liver due to a medication usually or some sort of toxic exposure can cause it as well.
That's what you're looking at. So, differential diagnosis, elevated alkaline phosphatase is
coxification to the liver through something, or if the person has a diagnosis of cancer, if there's
any bode metastasis. Those are the things that should be rolled out. Again, your alkaline phosphatase
is still with a normal limit. So, but still, if I was here, we'll call it as I'd at least suggest
should we do a CAT scan. Actually, prior to my visit in August of 21, I was taking homocysteine
resist. So, homocysteine resist, and there's other products of different names like that are
are mixtures of folate. This is methyl tetrahedral folate. I'm sure in this product in a thousand
milligrams of methylcobolivine. So, that would be the right thing to take. So, I get pretty anxious
with all of the challenges we're facing despite trying to keep a positive mindset fear takes over.
I know we can't feel it in a state of fear considering getting a script for THC from our
called CRGP. Well, I'm all in favor of that. So, THC can be very call me just to take for you
going to bed to help you get a good night's sleep. Because if you have anxiety that has your mind
racing while you sleep, then you're just not getting good sleep. So, I think that's a
witter-witter there. Take some THC before you go to bed. It would be really, really good.
I don't think there's any issues with your breast cancer with that.
Don't use, you could use labs. Labs is goes right to the same info at Connor's clinic. So, labs
at Connor's clinic, you could use that one too. Yep, it's just another name for the same email.
Is B-B-B negative blood type a concern if you decide to have surgery? I'm worried about that
and getting vaccinated blood if needed. Yeah, I would, you know, there's always a concern if I
getting vaccinated blood. I totally hear you on that. Absolutely. And I don't know what's better
where you go that you could ask for, you know, proof of that. It's on back that I just don't know
right now the state of the medical profession with that whole day. Yeah, that's tough.
Haven't had a scan. So, this is answering this alkaline phosphatase questions.
Since April 1st, don't have an oncologist have been taking Tylenol 500 milligrams
twice a day? That certainly could be the rise in alkaline phosphatase right there. So,
if you could change off of that to go back to like a THC product, which now you could just order THC
up the internet anywhere these days. So, if you could get off of the insides, I would highly suspect
that that's the problem. Also, I'm not sure if I'm detoxing my liver because I haven't done any
animals or castoral packs, just supplements and rife. I also take three different blood pressure pills
that I started in November. Oh, yes. Well, there could all be an issue. You know, if you do start
just not trying to sell you on copyinimus, but that's why you do copyinimus is it helps detoxify your
liver because it stimulates parasympathetics and what are your parasympathetics do when they're
stimulated, but they have colmein. They can help take care of some anxiety. They can help stimulate
interviewed response. They help with your detoxification pathways and go back to this question back here
about, you know, having anxiety and dealing with positive mindset, doing copyinimus can just be
colmein because it stimulates your parasympathetics and from a neurological standpoint,
your parasympathetics are the antithesis of your sympathetic which are your fight or flight
aka anxiety nervous system. So, your parasympathetics are your entire anxiety nervous system yourself
from a neurological standpoint, copyinimus, whether a person has cancer or not. You have anxiety,
copyinimus are right for you. If you have high blood pressure, copyinimus are right for you.
What is high blood pressure? So, high blood pressure is contraction of the smooth muscles that
is right underneath the endothelial lighting of your blood vessels. What are they controlled by?
Your sympathetic. So, what stimulating? What could you stimulate to decrease your blood pressure?
Quiz of the day. Ding, ding, ding, your parasympathetics. Yes, 50 points for you. If you do a coffee
edema, you will most likely lower your blood pressure. Lower your anxiety, increase your detoxification
pathways and coffeeinimus are so good for stimulating your immune system and just copy you getting rid
of anxiety. So, 500 points for coffeeinimus, coffeeinimus, win the quiz bowl of the day. Sorry,
well, I'm weird. But, all right. Thanks, you guys. It's been over an hour. I get it out next week
when I get back to the office one day. So, you guys, if you guys have a specific day, a bunch of people
already sent in, you know, the consensus that was Monday's based upon what you already sent in
and it's going to probably Monday evening that we do our protocol and a lab work Zoom call.
So, if you think otherwise, make sure you get that in as well. Thanks, everybody for being on.
I love you all. I'll be praying for you all. And, great. Monday sounds good to you too. Fantastic. And
we will talk to you next week. Bye-bye.